you may be thinking life cycles are
really important
however this section is on persisting
and recovering data it trust me I just
want to get us coding again however
these things are closely linked and
they're easy to get wrong if you don't
understand both as rato mentioned
Android saves the state of the
application in bundles you might have
had the idea that you just save all
sorts of information in these bundles
and not have to worry about any other
form of persistence but the thing is
these bundles go away as soon as the
user hits the back key in your main
activity it's really important that they
do this when the user chooses to close
your activity with the back key the
expectation is that next time your
activity is displayed it will be in the
default state if the user backgrounds
your app using the HOME key or the app
switcher the next time your activity is
created it should resume from the
current state